welcome to my round three recap I'm
going to try and keep this really brief
because lunch closes in a half hour so
let me try and keep this below 10
minutes but I was playing a player also
by the name of Eric from Norway he's I
think 12 or 13 years old and his rating
is just below 1900 but he had a really
good start to the tournament uh I think
upsetting someone around 2300 and then
also drawing someone high rated as well
so I knew that the game wasn't going to
be easy and it was probably pretty clear
that my opponent is underrated
um so I I went into the game without too
much preparation I couldn't really find
too many of my opponents games online so
I decided that I just wanted to play
chess and avoid too much opening Theory
and I chose to play the English opening
um another kind of weapon of mine that
I've played over the years and he played
Pawn C6 the only thing I knew about his
repertoire is that he sometimes displays
Queensland accepted but this usually
goes into like a slav or Karo Khan type
thing so I decided to play slightly
tricky move order Knight C3 D5 and E3
delaying Pawn D4
and he just went for the kind of typical
semi-stop setup I still delay D4 play
Queen C2 and then fiancado on the queen
side with B3 Bishop B2 and we got uh the
position after castling and I'll admit
that this wasn't specific preparation
I'm not sure if I've even like studied
this position specifically but I knew
some ideas and the move I really wanted
to play here was ponji for let me hide
the notation again avoid spoilers but
Pawn G4 is kind of a cool Gambit idea
and I just wasn't sure if it's like
objectively okay for white it's probably
a little bit dubious scheduling takes
and then Rook to G1 but then there's a
95 move and yeah I wasn't sure how to
evaluate this so I wanted to keep things
a bit more solid I played Bishop to E2
uh he played rookie eight and then again
I wanted to play G4 but I wasn't sure so
I ended up playing Pawn H3 uh
potentially preparing G4 and there is a
possible plan for white to play G4 or
Castle Queen side and then try and
attack on the king side especially with
the Phoenix Bishop but as we're going to
see the game took a different route
after he played Pawn T5 a very natural
move now I strike in the center with
Pawn to D4
and I actually remembered
um a game I had studied probably over 10
years ago that went Pawnee for Knight D2
it was a game between teamworkure of and
Ray Robson I believe they had this
position except the pawn was on H2 and
The Rook was on f8 and gray of one like
a really really nice game with white
pieces ended up playing G4 G5 casting
and just storming on the king side yeah
that that didn't happen in this game
because my opponent took on D4 and then
things uh simplified a little bit in the
center after 95 I take and then uh he
takes with Knight on D5 which I think
was a slight mistake generally if you're
going to have the isolated Pawn you want
to try and keep minor pieces on the
board
um so I think Pawn takes was a little
bit more accurate but after Knight takes
I was happy to trade a pair of knights
and black still lines up with this
so-called iqp isolated Pawn and
essentially going forward the game kind
of revolves around this pawn and the
general plan for white when I'm playing
against the pawn is to try and trade
minor pieces and then eventually just
double up Rooks and um and and hopefully
win the pawn later in the game
um but of course first I had to complete
development I castled
before I castled I took some time
because I had to calculate this weird
sack Bishop H3 GH3 Queen H4 I concluded
it wasn't working for black
but I'm trying to remember
ah instead of uh taking I I think I have
F4 which should be okay for white
um and then black is going to lose one
of these pieces
so I wasn't too scared of Bishop H3
um my opponent played Bishop E7 and then
I just wanted to to simplify things even
more played 9-3 we traded and then Queen
to G5 which simultaneously defends D5
but also hits H3 so nice active move
from my opponent and here I decided to
not directly defend H3 but counter
attack with Rook FT1 and I make it so
black can't really take because after
Rook D5 uh yeah black is losing
something here
so I was happy to see Bishop C6 Bishop
is now on kind of a passive square and
then after Rook D4 I am threatening Rook
to G4 with the skewer uh my opponent
plays Bishop T5 I still play Rook G4
Queen F6 we trade Bishops so overall I'm
just achieving my goal of trading most
of the minor pieces now I have a happy
bishop and my points Bishop is very sad
and most things about this position are
just really happy for whites uh I'm
ready to
double up maybe even triple up on the
the d-pawn and there's a very typical
idea when you play against I said Pawn
if the opponent defends it via d8
eventually there is uh this break E4
um because there's going to be the
nephil pin on the D file
and around this point I was remembering
a game between korchnoy and karpov where
karpov was also playing against ISO pawn
and it was just a positional Masterpiece
and it featured a very similar position
to this except I think the Bishops were
off the board it was just some major
pieces so if anyone's interested in that
game you can Google uh quartz noi karpov
ISO pawn and then probably find it if I
find it I'll leave a link in the
description but anyway uh the game
continued from here Rook D1 and then
things got a little bit weird after Rook
F5 Queen D2 rookie 8 Queen D4 my
opponent uh kind of went all in on the
king side played Rook to E5 defending
the pawn but leaving the a pawn hanging
uh and I went ahead and just took the
pawn uh and then each five so things
were getting a little bit unsettling
because it seems like there's a lot of
Firepower for black
um some initiative I always have to
watch out for Rook takes F3 uh with this
exchange sack also have to watch out for
Pawn D4 but I found uh what I think was
a nice idea here to just put the Rook on
G3 a very stable Square defending F3 and
then after each four I just moved back
to G4 I think everything was under
control I don't think it's ever good for
black to take because when I take back
and
um yeah there's a line here actually
takes takes takes
uh I think I was gonna play Rook to D4
and then each four should fall he's also
Queen B in the error so my opponent
didn't take on F3 uh he was following
very low on time as we see here already
below a minute I had um just under 40
minutes uh and then uh he plays G6 I
play Rook T4 just trying to solidify and
after Rook to G5 I play Rook F4 uh and
then essentially I lifted both Rooks so
even though the FNG files are closed I'm
still making use of them with the Rooks
and then I ended up winning another Pawn
after it takes takes throw in the check
and then took on each board so not only
am I about two pawns here but I also
have a mating attack threatening made in
one and the finish the game uh was kind
of funny because my opponent's king went
for a small stroll and uh yeah it wasn't
uh wasn't actually easy to find the
clear mate
um even though the King was like just
smack in the center on E6 but eventually
I found my way gave a few checks and
then um I found a line here essentially
to win The Rook is to play Queen A3 King
E6 and then Bishop G4 the point being
that I'm I'm provoking F5 uh F5 wasn't
played but if it is played I would take
the queen bring the bishop back and
there's no way for Bach to stop each
four uh trapping The Rook on G5
so my opponent played Rook takes G4
maybe hoping that I would automatically
recapture and wander my queen but I I
took first and he resigned given that uh
White's gonna be up the exchange and a
couple Pawns
so that was round three I think overall
pretty smooth game I was happy with
opening choice and just the instructive
positional nature
uh I left the window open and there's a
bug that I think is trying to attack me
so I've ever ended now uh thanks for
watching stay tuned for more Recaps I'll
see you guys later